scp-105 77 - - radio contact log this
log took place one hour after firing SCP
157 7 - 1 on the 7th of the 13th 2000
acre a swing come in ikura swing this is
skipping stone 23 please identify
yourself you must be the one who's
incessantly requesting supplies it's
jolly good - hey Romeo world fruit
you'll identify yourself immediately or
you will be forced to land a class
cheeky impertinent dog food
I'm Royal Air Force sergeant no wood
service number can you identify yourself
in reciprocity governor old chap not
with this much detail that's classified
you can just call me dr. Lionel you can
just call me Norwood dr. Lionel Rankin
service number but just details
why do you request so many supplies I do
not often visit the same location more
than mon-sol bean we were trying to
figure out the process how this works
how this works dr. Lionel you fire the
flare I bring the supplies I drop them
this is how my missions always work what
else to try to figure out a chap how
long have you been delivering supplies
sergeant you can just call me no dr.
Lionel Rankin service number is just
details how long is irrelevant a flare
is fired and I answer I have delivered
supplies for many sergeant things don't
appear that simple on our end are you
aware of any anomalous properties of
your aircraft
no there's nothing unusual what about
your cargo can you tell me about it
no there's nothing unusual
did you know that Norwood was killed in
action on June 1940 yes then who are you
you can just call me Norwood dr. Lionel
you've dropped some intriguing supplies
sergeant will you tell me where they
come from
where do you land to load and refuel
your plane no that's classified
information chap consider it a personal
favor
no that's classified information chap
pip pip jolly right in that case can you
tell me why all of your delivered
supplies are flawed and useless
delivered supplies dr. Lionel my
superiors have determined that you do
not require emergency supplies a
functional utilitarian quality dr.
Lionel governor and fruit and who would
these superiors be it's classified
information champ pivotally right by me
I'm sorry to hear that our instruments
show that you're reaching your exit
point I am it's quite cold I cannot stop
you from using the signal of ice dr.
Lisle Chapel will I politely ask as one
Englishman to another stop wasting my
time I have supplies to deliver at this
point in the recording Icarus wing
ceases radio contact SCP 157 7-2
vanishes at the expected location
you